les otages français libérés raq ondes
courtes valdan condamne israël sommet
franco allemand à hambourg confirmation
d'un axe paris bonn londres
fin des négociations à l'opéra les
concessions seront elles suffisantes
deuxième victoire en montagne that may
van impe garde le maillot jaune
ce que vous coûte vraiment votre voiture
c'est le dossier de ce journal
bonsoir fait hier soir à quelques heures
de l'extraordinaire opérations du
commando israélien une question se pose
est quel a été pendant la séquestration
des passagers de l'airbus par les
palestiniens
la position exacte du président
ougandais idi amin dada
tous les témoignages des otages venant
de tel aviv et débarquant hier à orry
corrobore amin dada et les terroristes
étaient complices en revanche dès son
arrivée l'équipage d'air france faisait
entendre un autre son de cloche et
rendait hommage au président ougandais
pour son souci d'assurer leur sécurité
leur confort
sur le plan diplomatique internationale
la même dualité se retrouve si dans le
camp occidental
la satisfaction est quasi générale la
france toutefois n'a fait aucun
commentaire officiel l'union soviétique
et les pays africains condamnent
l'opération israélienne
en outre et c'est à souligner le
secrétaire général de l'onu monsieur
cours de valdaï s'est élevé devant
l'organisation de l'unité africaine l'ua
contre ce qu'il a appelé une incursion
israélienne en ouganda la fin de la
tante la fin de l' angoisse
les quatorze français qui se trouvait
parmi les derniers otages des
palestiniens avec eux les 12 membres de
l'équipage de l'airbus d'air france ont
été longuement acclamé les embrassades
des retrouvailles les larmes de joie
mêlée à des vivats pour israël des
hourras pour l'équipage l'émotion de
parts en retrouvant leurs enfants et
puis les déclarations on peut être
partisane certainement passionnés
d'hommes ou de femmes ayant vécu une
détention qu'ils reprochent en commun
aux palestiniens et aux ougandais les
forces ougandaises était manifestement
de connivence avec les commandos de
façon tout à fait évidente avec
embrassades entre les commandos et les
forces ougandaises avec également
échange d'armes entre les commandos et
les forces ougandaises et à l'arrivée
avec des chaudes félicitations des
ougandais au commando c'était absolument
évident pourtant dès leur arrivée les
membres de l'équipage d'air france -
sensible sans doute à la joie des
israéliens
il est un communiqué dans lequel il
souligne l aide apportée par le
président amin dada sur l'aéroport
d'entebbe
mais nous avons toujours été gardés par
le commando qui avait reçu quelques
renforts de palestine et nous avons
toujours eu affaire à ces hommes là ce
sont toujours eux qui nous ont gardés
vous dit l'attitude des autorités
hollandaises a été donnée nous fournir
la nourriture la 7e c'est ce confort e
petit confort matériel descend on qu'on
puisse dormir
il y avait quand même des enfants des
femmes vous avez eu des contacts avec le
président mahinda oui dans une attaque
du noir lui-même et nous disait qu'il
était en contact avec différents pays
sans les nommer et qui fut et déployer
ses efforts pour résoudre la question
l'émission pas dans le secret des dieux
avec commande en combien de temps s'est
opéré
le raid israélien contre +15 munich en
israël une fois passée la stupéfaction
devant l'exploit de ce qu'on appelle
désormais ici les gardes ntb il reste un
soulagement une joie immense dans les
rues de tel aviv hier et gens
s'embrassent
une des raisons c'est que pendant les
six jours du calvaire des otages les
israéliens ont cru que leur pays pour la
première fois de son histoire elle est
devant céder aux exigences des
terroristes
le coup d'éclat entebbe a donc rendu à
israël sa fierté et sa confiance en soi
pour le gouvernement israélien c'est
aussi le soulagement
le premier ministre itzhak rabin qui
avait été insulté par les familles des
otages a joué son va-tout un échec
sanglant et son avenir politique
s'arrêter là
or grâce au succès d'hier la popularité
des dirigeants israéliens n'a jamais été
aussi forte pour le gouvernement
israélien c'est d'abord une confirmation
de sa politique de ne jamais céder au
chantage mais aussi dans l'euphorie
actuelle on pense avoir montré comment
stopper le terrorisme ne serez au coeur
a pas
les autres appareils qui nous espérons
qu'ils aient tout l'événement vont
prendre les mesures nécessaires
justement trouvé cela ne se répète plus
et surtout qui a eu les reins lutte
acharnée contre l'égouttement c'est un
risque pareil pour qu'il ne venant
pousse pas lui en loi sur notre monde
autrement notre vie de tous ses membres
à un rival donc pour l'instant la
politique du gouvernement et ray allen
reste la même ne pas céder jamais aux
exigences des terroristes exactement
cela politique des bases du mouvement
il fera justement des pas encourager des
chantages keiko et ses bâches sur les
jeux avec tv
les représentants des états africains
réunis à l'île maurice pour le sommet de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine ont
tous condamné l'action du commando
cette position était attendu mais la
réaction du secrétaire général de l'onu
monsieur sur bonne dame présent un
produit qui a condamné également
l'intervention d'israël sur le
territoire ougandais est une voix
discordante parmi celles des pays
occidentaux
peut-on prononcer le mot d'israël sans
soulever des passions sans être taxé
soit d'antisémitisme flagrant soit de
procès mitis miron t d'autant que leur
est de kampala met en évidence une fois
de plus seraient intelligence
l'imagination et le courage les trois
qualités si dans les vertus des
israéliens à cela s'ajoute avons là le
plaisir à peu sommaire de voir monsieur
amin dada rouler dans la farine
lui qui depuis longtemps joué les grands
de ce monde sans s'apercevoir que
personne ne le regardais plus sentiment
mise à part on s'aperçoit d'abord que la
souveraineté de certains pays d'afrique
ne vaut pas grand chose le son diplôme
as ensuite qu'une opération de commando
bien mener à un effet de dissuasion
aussi efficace parfois qu'une lourde
armée en réserve leçon de stratégie
militaire
on s'aperçoit encore le son de fatalité
que les israéliens
n'ayant rien à perdre et les
palestiniens ayant tout à gagner
qu'ils se ressemblent au fond en se
battant les uns et les autres le dos au
mur ben gourion tu disais je crois que
chaque israélien est un soldat sous les
armes
chaque pays signent un doit ressentir le
même état tous sont condamnés à frapper
plus fort et répondre plus du
l'israélien a parce que le monde entier
les abandonne dans les couloirs de l'onu
les palestiniens parce que certains de
leurs chefs se prennent pour des
présidents et que certains de leurs
frères les fusils dans les rues de
beyrouth
tampa l'art n'est qu'un épisode de
feuilleton n'est pas fini il y aura
d'autres aventures d'autres otages
d'autres victimes d'autres suspense
surtout à moins que les spectateurs
c'est à dire les autres pays du monde se
décide à tendre la main je veux dire
attends t'es vraiment de résoudre le
problème de la survie d'israël et de
celle des palestiniens
il ne faut pas croire que la visite de
monsieur giscard d'estaing au chancelier
schmidt sera assombri par le récent
voyage du président français à londres
non car monsieur callaghan vient de tout
raconter à vient de séjourner abonnés a
déjà tout raconté monsieur schmitt de la
rencontre franco britannique
c'est d'ailleurs ce que monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing appelle des
consultations triangulaire sur nos
relations bilatérales réciproque
la dernière rencontre des deux chefs
d'état s'étaient déroulés près de nice
suivant cet exemple de décentralisation
monsieur schmitt
délaissant bonne a choisi hambourg c'est
dans le cadre simple et intime de sa
maison de banlieue dans une cité
paisible au milieu deux voisins
représentant de commerce ou éleveurs de
lapins pour le plaisir que helmut
schmidt recevra ce soir à dîner son ami
valéry giscard d'estaing en somme
helmut schmidt ses forces pour ses
électeurs de ressembler à un chancelier
monsieur tout le monde
en recevant chez lui les grands de ce
monde et singulièrement un président
français populaire auprès du public
allemand
mais à quelques kilomètres de son
domicile dans l'enceinte de l'aéroport
de hambourg
helmut schmidt ne pouvait pas échapper
aussi facilement au protocole et à la
grande politique
il s'agit maintenant de reconnu les pots
cassés entre paris et bonn au pouzin
printemps trop chaud et trop nerveux ce
sera l'objet principal de ce sommet
franco allemand sur les rives de l'elbe
dans cette oeuvre d'apaisement au tant
le président français que le chancelier
allemand ne se feront pas trop
d'illusions sur les effets de leurs très
réelle amitié personnelle
les îles argens subsistent en effet
entre paris et bonn et l'existence de ce
qu'on a appelé la kz paris bonn n'a pas
réussi à les dissiper alors une autre
formule semble bien être en voie de
l'application sous la forme d'une sorte
de relation triangulaire londres bonn
paris en fait on retrouve là l'idée de
directoire lancé lors du dernier sommet
de nice par le président français sans
cependant que le terme directoire soit à
présent cité peut-être pouvons-nous pas
froisser les petits pays de la
communauté européenne peut voir peu
satisfait de voir résumé l'europe des
neuf à un simple triangle il ne fait
cependant pas de doute ici que sur cette
question
helmut schmidt après une sorte de virage
à 180 degrés pour rester le regio
maîtrise comme valéry giscard d'estaing
il semble convaincu que dans le monde
politique et économique actuelle
l'europe se doit de prendre des
décisions très rapidement surtout par
rapport aux évolutions assez
imprévisible et rapide sur les marchés
mondiaux de l'énergie et des matières
problème première et cela est
fondamental mais les deux hommes d'état
restent divergent quant aux méthodes et
à la philosophie de cette action en gros
et surtout par rapport aux pays du tiers
monde les français restent assez
pragmatique et dirigiste alors que les
allemands restent les champions les
apôtres du libre échange total l'arrivée
des anglais pragmatique dans ce club à 3
n'est donc pas vu comme une chose très
mauvaise ou mauvaise autant par paris et
bonn et en définitive au cours de ce
sommet de rembourse cette ville libre
qui subit en quelque sorte les appels du
large
cette ville qui est aussi la patrie d'un
chancelier allemand angle fine
anglophile et anglophones on peut dire
que la grande bretagne ne sera plus
présente que jamais dans ce passé au
cours des dialogues franco allemand
demain session parlementaire
extraordinaire au sénat un refrain connu
les plus values à l'assemblée nationale
les députés vont se pencher sur un
projet gouvernemental concernant le code
électoral alors tout d'abord il s'agit
de la sectorisation de toulouse et nice
sur le modèle pratique que l'on pratique
déjà à marseille à lyon
ces deux villes sont partagés en secteur
ce qui permet au conseil municipal de ne
pas être forcément me gêne puisque des
listes différentes peuvent y être
représentés ce premier point ne devrait
pas rencontrer d'obstacles quant au
deuxième et il concerne le relèvement de
la barre qui permet aux candidats de se
présenter au deuxième tour des élections
il lui fallait jusqu'ici au moins 10%
des suffrages il lui en faudrait 15 % et
ses lacs encore une fois beaucoup de
députés risquent de ne pas être d'accord
à première vue la modification
gouvernementale peut paraître mineur en
élevant la barre 17e ont éliminé les
candidatures fantaisistes
mais outre le fait que la mesure sera
dur pour les écologistes on s'aperçoit
qu'aux dernières législatives
elle aurait fait des ravages 50 % des
candidats centristes auraient été
éliminés 40% chez les socialistes 30%
chez les communistes 10% que les isc
gardien 5% chez les gaullistes mieux un
député n'aurait pas pu être élu claude
michel député de l'eure aurait obtenu au
avait obtenu au premier tour de 73 14 %
des suffrages
il aurait donc été éliminé à voir les
chiffres on comprend pourquoi demain
l'opposition va voter contre le projet
mais il est plus difficile d'expliquer
le tollé qu'il suffit à du dr lui dr qui
nous l'avons vu perdre est peu de plume
de laventure lui la raison c'est que la
loi si elle était votée
vous serez davantage encore à l'alliance
les parties moyens que sont les
républicains indépendants et le cds pour
ces deux groupes l'accord est
indispensable dès le premier tour sous
peine de mort ainsi vers et ont lu des
airs face à ce qu'elle a toujours
redouté le front des centres qui peut
apparaître comme une machine de guerre
anti gaulliste
voilà pourquoi demain on va encore
tempêté dans le groupe de claude labbé
le projet de loi aura du mal en sortir
indemne
si contrairement aux autres années les
leaders syndicaux ne nous ont pas
menacée verbalement d'un été très chaud
il ne faut pas croire que le front
social est étale à l'opéra la question
posée a le mérite d'être clair le parler
garnier va-t-il oui ou non fermer ses
portes
la réponse est pour bien pensée dans dix
jours que le premier ministre tranchera
et d'après le calendrier imposé par
monsieur chirac
syndicats et direction doivent achever
leurs négociations demain
vous vous souvenez sans doute que dans
une lettre adressée au secrétaire d'état
à la culture le premier ministre réclame
et anne opéra démocratiser et surtout
capable de fonctionner sans être un
gouffre financier économies sur les
spectacles économie aussi sur les
dépenses du personnel des compromis ont
été faits de part et d'autre part
l'administration et les syndicats reste
à savoir s'ils seront jugés suffisants
par monsieur scheer sur deux points
l'organisation du travail et le problème
des tournées de l'opéra on est parvenu
tant bien que mal un accord mais il ya
encore deux obstacles la diffusion des
spectacles à la radio et à la télévision
la direction ne veut rien versé au
personnel pour une première diffusion
les syndicats ont fait ce matin une
contre-proposition aucun salaire
supplémentaire mais les versements des
sociétés de télévision ou de radio à
l'opéra devons être partagé entre le
personnel mobilisé pour la diffusion
cela ne coûtera pas un sou a loupé un
signe encourageant
monsieur lieberman le patron de terra un
décidé d'étudier la contre-proposition
syndicale deuxième obstacle les ballets
de l'opéra
les danseurs étoiles les premiers
danseurs et les cadres seront licenciés
le 1er janvier prochain
mesure qui ne préjuge pas des
réengagements éventuelle mais qui a jeté
la consternation de plus pour le corps
de ballet les horaires proposés par la
direction leur paraissent irréalistes
voire inhumain jusqu'à 10h30 de danse
par jour d'ici là encore signes
encourageants monsieur lieberman prend
lui-même les négociations en main de
signes encourageants en signe
encourageant au devrait pouvoir à bout
un accord global d'ici à demain reprise
des négociations aussi dans la presse
après cinq mois de discussions le
syndicat cgt du livre a rencontré
aujourd'hui le syndicat patronal de la
presse parisienne ainsi que les
directeurs du figaro et de france soir
qui avait quitté il ya un mois le
syndicat patronal
il s'agit de mettre au point l'accord
sur les conditions de travail et
d'emploi des ouvriers de presse alors
que les imprimeries ce modernisme
des bus d'un nouveau procès à propos de
la corse devant la cour de sûreté de
l'état aujourd'hui celui de serge 4
chiards il est accusé d'avoir tué le
brigadier de crs serge cassard lors de
la nuit d'émeute de bastia le 27 août
dernier les juges seront les mêmes que
pour edmond simeoni et ses coïnculpés
autonomistes corses
le procès doit durer une semaine mais
sans trop préjugés on peut déjà dire que
le climat du procès de serge cacciari
sera bien différent de celui qui a vu
condamner à edmond simeoni à cinq ans de
prison dont deux avec sursis
au liban la bataille des camps
palestiniens de la banlieue de beyrouth
continue pour la 12è journée consécutive
comme d'habitude on se bat aussi avec
des communiqués hier soir les chrétiens
conservateurs annonçaient qu'ils
contrôlaient la majeure partie du camp
de tell el zaatar mais les palestiniens
déclaré qu'il venait de repousser leurs
ennemis une chose est certaine le bilan
de cette guerre civile s'alourdit des
centaines de morts et de blessés chaque
jour ce soir en raison de la poursuite
des combats la conférence qui devait
réunir les principales parties au
conflit libanais a été annulé en espagne
il ne devrait pas y avoir deux ministres
réformateurs dans le gouvernement de
monsieur adolfo suarez l'un après
l'autre en effet les ministres dits
libéraux de l'ancien gouvernement
monsieur iribarne ministre de
l'intérieur le compte de mots tricot des
affaires étrangères même les cieux pic
ware et gameiro refuse de participer au
nouveau gouvernement
ils pensent tous que monsieur suarez le
président du gouvernement n'ira pas
assez loin dans les réformes et lui
reproche aussi de s'entourer de
ministres appartenant à l'opus dei et de
jeunes technocrates
enfin conséquence des élections
italienne le président de la chambre des
députés est un communiste
le président du sénat est un démocrate
chrétien une régime and i'm into réforme
fanni en fait ces deux élections se sont
déroulées sans aucun problème à
l'amiable
les deux principaux partis italiens se
partageant les deux chambres
à la suite d'un accord négocié ce
week-end entre les principaux partis
politiques de la péninsule
les communistes très satisfait de cet
accord voudrait bien que les discussions
continuent dans un tel climat lorsqu'il
s'agira de gouverner le pays
ce n'est pas à nous ceux de la vieille
europe qu'il faut expliquer le sentiment
de fierté que donne une histoire
on comprend facilement l'entousiasme
compte éprouvée ces millions
d'américains à célébrer leurs deux cents
ans d'existence
mais ce qui toujours nous a frappés
c'est le goût il me dirait qu'ils ont dû
confettis et de la revue à grand
spectacle hier des clochettes aux chars
gigantesques et aux diverses
reconstitution historique
l'amérique s'est défoulé dans un super
show
tout commence au son des cloches cloches
de la liberté
d'abord celle du porte à lyon un travail
dont le président faure pire la corde
et celle de philadelphie berceau de la
nation la ville de franklin où fut
signée la déclaration d'indépendance
reconstitution dans le port de new york
200 grands voiliers comme ceux qui
apportaient aux insurgés les secours de
la vieille europe et puisqu'on
reconstitue pourquoi pas la bataille de
gettysburg ou le nord évolutionniste
batterie lorsque la belle joue pas en
professant 87 ans après la boum et
partent on l'a fait
y compris bien sûr sûr
si on ne peut même plus compter sur
l'isr alors vraiment les tours de france
sont plus ce qu'ils étaient car
finalement c'est 10e étape dans le fait
que confirmer les qualités de grimpeur
devin ni paix deux hôtels mec confirmé
le retour de la forme de thévenet et
surtout réaffirmer que poulidor est
toujours là de cette étape qui allait de
bourg d'oisans à montgenèvre 168 km avec
trois difficultés le lautaret classé 2e
catégorie l'île aux arrêts et surtout
parti dans la descente de l'izoard
l'ascension du montgenèvre partie donc
dans la descente l'exploit aujourd'hui
de l'italien baronchelli qui a bien
failli créer une grande surprise après
avoir connu il est vrai une défaillance
qui restera mémorable dans tous les
esprits car la surprise ce soir que ce
serait bien évidemment que baronchelli
puis le gagner le tour de france
baronchelli qui est parti dans la
descente de l'izoard ou au sommet il y
avait vent nimbuzz hotmail que poulidor
galdos lopez carril pesaro donna
thévenet de l'illberg saglio bergamo
baronchelli panizza eric omis descente
sous l'averse descente dantesques et
camer be donc au jeune italien l'un des
plus jeunes de ce tour de france est
l'un des plus grands espoirs que le
cyclisme transat transalpin nous a
permis de voir ces dernières années de
réaliser l'un de ses exploits en
exploite y prendra fin à 5 km du sommet
regarder à 20km baronchelli était à une
minute 55 du groupe van impe à 6 km de
l'arrivée vent ni peut se détacher avec
votre mail qu puis à 5 km de l'arrivée
baronchelli posséder encore cinquante et
une seconde à 4 km 35 secondes à trois
kilomètres il était rejoint et dépassé
rejoint et dépassé par qui partout les
virtuoses que le cyclisme professionnel
connaît en son sein c'est à dire par
raymond poulidor très à l'aise autant
qui hier au moins bernard thévenet
quelque peu retrouvé diop tout mail gay
lucien van impe le maillot jaune
baronchelli et des talards en détresse à
l'arrière puisque ce soir son retard au
classement général atteint 5 minutes et
50 secondes et on peut dire que
l'italien a perdu aujourd'hui le tour de
france et dire que ce ne fut pas une
étape pour rien avec ses hommes
sont regroupés les meilleurs du
classement général l'enzyme qui a très
bien lutté à chaque fois aux premières
loges les que la route se présentait
sous ses coups de pédales avec une pente
assez importantes c'est-à-dire dans
l'izoard et en particulier dans les
derniers kilomètres de montgenèvre avec
un bernard thévenet qui n'a pas rechigné
à la tâche aujourd'hui qui a été un peu
moins volontaire peut-être cuillère mais
qui finalement a retrouvé pendant une
demi heure à peu près le rythme qu'on
lui connaissait regardez bien aussi
cette image c'est raymond delisle à un
kilomètre du sommet qui a essayé
d'attaquer et finalement personne
n'empêchera hotmail que vainqueur d'hier
d'être encore le vainqueur du jour
d'huile battra dans l'ordre l'image sera
très fugitive thévenet van impe quelle
dose bertoglio et polydor
mais plus maintenant aucun doute 1976
sera une année faste pour l'industrie
automobile
ces voitures qui trouvaient
difficilement preneur il y a deux ans se
vendent de mieux en mieux aujourd'hui
à preuve depuis janvier les
immatriculations de véhicules neufs ont
augmenté de 40 % conséquence une
progression très nette de la production
au mois de mai dernier recette connue la
cadence était de 13 1120 voitures par
jour c'est-à-dire 14 % de plus qu'en mai
tous les records seront battus en juin à
cette demande très ferme sur le marché
intérieur pas de 800 mille voitures
neuves vendues pendant les cinq premiers
mois de l'année il faut ajouter un bond
de 7 % de nos exportations à l'étranger
est ce que cette reprise industrielle va
se poursuivre les constructeurs sont
optimistes mais prudents pour la rentrée
une chose est sûre en tout cas c'est que
les voitures sont de plus en plus cher
et qu'il est de plus en plus coûteux de
se mettre au volant en juillet 1974
cette voiture clé-en-main coûtait 12
1860 de francs
deux ans après aujourd'hui pour le même
prix vous n'auriez que cela c'est-à-dire
une voiture sans moteur
autrement dit pas de voiture du tout
aujourd'hui cette voiture neuve coûte
dix sept mille neuf cent francs les en
main
une augmentation de 39% en 24 mois
des pièces de fonte qui servent à
fabriquer ce moteur ont augmenté de 40%
en deux ans pour sortir une coque de
voitures des places il faut près d'une
tonne d'acier aux relations avec lequel
on a moulé cette carrosserie passer un
bond de 39%
une hausse qui se répercute aussi sur
les portières et les cas pendant la même
période le prix du cuivre a doublé l'or
le cuivre est à la base de tous les
circuits électriques les gommes les
tissus synthétiques sont eux aussi plus
cher conséquence une hausse de 30% sur
les pneumatiques
il y a bien sûr aussi des augmentations
purement technique par exemple la
ceinture de sécurité ou le double
circuit de freinage obligatoire + 3 %
depuis deux ans aussi les salaires et
les charges sociales ont augmenté pour
le r5 coût de la main d'oeuvre plus 130
% reste l'énergie qui fait tourner les
machines pour amener une r5 en bout de
chaîne de montage il faut une tonne et
demie de fioul lourd plus 233%
c'est fini vive les vacances cette
voiture neuve que je viens d'acheter m'a
quand même coûté 5000 francs de plus
qu'il ya deux ans clef en main et il
faut y ajouter le prix de l'essence
celui des parkings celui des péages
d'autoroute
le prix de l'assurance et aussi le coût
de l'entretien de la voiture
bref en deux ans tout a augmenté pour se
mettre au volant il faut prendre une
assurance c'est l'augmentation la moins
spectaculaire
je payais 678 francs par an en juillet
je viens de payer 743 france +14 6%
ce n'est pas énorme car le coût d'un
accident a augmenté de 40% en deux ans
si la hausse a été si faible en
proportion de l'augmentation du coût des
accidents
c'est grâce à la réduction du nombre des
accidents du nombre des tués et du
nombre des blessés
en deux ans il y a eu 16 pour cent tués
en moins 6 % de blessés en moins
cependant avec un parc en augmentation
de 8%
les assurés ont donc touché les
bénéfices de la politique de sécurité
routière
le prix de l'essence lui aussi à
augmenter un franc 75 litre de super en
1974 un franc 96 en 1976 pas de plein à
moins de 60 francs
dans les villes le tarif horaire des
parkings a progressé en deux ans de 50
centimes à un franc sans compter bien
sûr les contraventions pour partir en
vacances en prenant l'autoroute il
faudra dépenser entre 10 et 15 % de plus
qu il y a deux ans les sept voitures il
faut l'entretenir
les pièces détachées ont augmenté de 30%
reste la main d'oeuvre 33 francs de
l'heure en juillet 1974 38 francs 44 en
juillet 1976 un coup de massue quand
c'est une grosse réparation moins cher
toutefois qu'en allemagne les salariés
les ouvriers qui ont été nécessaires à
cette réparation ont une augmentation
depuis fui à 74 2 29 60 % et les charges
incidente ont approché 22%
donc à l'heure actuelle on peut dire que
l'entreprise se trouve dans une
situation plus défavorable par rapport à
ce qu'elle avait en juillet 74 mais est
ce que ces augmentations vont continuer
tout dépend de l'élévation des salaires
et de l'accélération du poids des
charges sociales
si l'entretien d'une voiture est restée
relativement raisonnable pendant deux
ans son prix à l'achat beaucoup plus
augmenté que le coût de la vie bien sûr
les constructeurs sont dans une période
faste après la crise
mais est ce que les français accepteront
de subir a défini mans et hausse
disproportionnée
c'est vrai qu'on a toujours l'air de se
plaindre mais je vous assure que nous
pauvres parisiens
on attend leur âge avec impatience les
bordelais hier l'attendait trucy mais
vous allez le voir sur ces images il
n'avait pas demandé le déluge grêle vent
et pluie résultats des inondations dans
les rues et de nombreux dégâts
c'est simple 27 milliards de litres
d'eau sont tombés en moins de 30 minutes
mais est ce que ces augmentations vont
continuer tout dépend de l'élévation des
salaires et de l'accélération du poids
des charges sociales
si l'entretien d'une voiture est restée
relativement raisonnable pendant deux
ans son prix à l'achat beaucoup plus
augmenté que le coût de la vie bien sûr
les constructeurs sont dans une période
faste après la crise
mais est ce que les français accepteront
de subir indéfiniment et hausse
disproportionnée
c'est vrai qu'on a toujours l'air de se
plaindre mais je vous assure que nous
pauvres parisiens
on attend leur âge avec impatience les
bordelais hier l'attendent est aussi
mais vous allez le voir sur ces images
il n'avait pas demandé le déluge grêle
vent et pluie résultats des inondations
dans les rues et de nombreux dégâts
c'est simple 27 milliards de litres
d'eau sont tombés en moins de 30 minutes
alors le temps aujourd'hui et bien s'il
était un peu plus frais dans les régions
de l'ouest et le long du littoral de
l'atlantique partout ailleurs et cette
carte en témoigne il fait il a fait
lourd et orageux demain demain toujours
de la chaleur des nuages et des orages
mais ils devaient faire plus frais des
côtes de l'atlantique aux pyrénées haut
languedoc
des éclaircies du pas de calais à
l'alsace mais ce ne sera pas encore
demain qu'une bénéfique petite pluie
fine viendra nous réconforter avec la
rédaction d'antenne 2 je vous souhaite
cependant de passer une très agréable
soirée
à demain bonsoir si vous n'avez pas pu
assister à l'intégralité de ce journal
et bien voici les principaux titres
israël fait son commando mais courte
valdes à une demande la réunion du
conseil de sécurité sommet
franco-allemand confirmation du triangle
paris bonn londres l'opéra et la presse
de négociations sur le point d'aboutir
lucien van impe maillot jaune pour la
11e étape
à 22h50 la dernière édition du journal
avec bernard pradines lot